you
hey Isaac do you get those cheezits from
the store yet no there's no reason we
have cheese nips in the cupboard excuse
me I said cheez-its yeah cheese nips not
Jesus they're the same exact thing
though they are not the same thing you
do not understand well just go back to
the store and get the other ones he'll
take like 20 minutes what I'm not going
to the store again last time I got
robbed you didn't get robbed you
defended yourself well almost robbed but
still it's the same thing you're such a
wuss well why can't you just accept that
they're the same exact thing calm down
huh I'm with master chief on this one
they aren't the same because everybody
knows cheese nips are better don't even
start Sammis Sam is don't pick the other
side you're just gonna make it more
angry no cheez-its are better does
anyone even listening to me right now
what it's just a fact totally talking to
myself here nope nope nope not even food
is could say anything I want Oh mr. IE
toothpaste just to survive nobody would
even care are you kidding yum she's no
stupid have you lost your cheese nips
are more better cheese like cheesy I
don't know they're the same shape but do
necessarily mean that they're the same
yeah I'm gonna kill both of you in your
sleep and then I'm going to set the
house on fire
Shea's nips are way better than cheez-it
you thought that hurt oh you want it you
want to see some pain no I don't mean
for you have diaper rash what are you
talking about she's new to know anything
you have cheese nips you have no idea
what cheese nips are these nibs are way
better cheese nip and then I'm gonna eat
puppies and like it cheese nips cheese
nips cheese nips nobody cares Isaac I
expected more from you they're not the
same thing and samis here an idiot Jesus
cheez-its is right that's probably what
you haven't it a mask of yours oh yeah
well cheese nips are culturally
insensitive to the Wisconsin Japanese
she knits Jesus is culturally
insensitive to Chaz Bono wait guys this
is getting a little out of control oh
that's it you're done oh you think
that's funny
I
so you guys want to have some goldfish
crackers oh yeah that's fine with me i
just lost a lot of blood hold on